beim wahlkampf in österreich kleiden
sich sowohl hc strache als auch
sebastian kurz unglaublich tech und bei
diesem neuen faschismus da mache ich mit
und gründer eine populistische partei
dazu treffe ich den populismus experten
und ehemaligen jörg haider berater
stefan petzner
wir sind ja ein aussteiger aus dem
populismus
es ist ja quasi wie die geschichte in
der bibel vom saulus zum paulus oder in
ihrem fall vom hetzner zum petzner ich
möchte ja auch eine erfolgreiche
populistische partei gründen und da
möchte ich mir von ihnen einfach als
expertin paar tipps holen
es ist immer gut wenn man wenn man harte
themen polarisierende themen das sind
natürlich keine flüchtlinge zu weiter
und integration schön verpacken kann und
auch ein gesicht und eine stimme hat
dass das angenehm schön rüber bringt ja
deswegen habe ich das ja gesagt sie war
es dann kurz ist jung und typisch was
ich schon immer ein bisschen ähnlich ja
vier jahre und dann könnte man schon was
draus machen das ist mal wichtig ja also
dass sie dass sie der absolut
unumstrittene chef sinken die niemand
ins handwerk pfuscht jungen eigenen
partei leute näher
sonst geht es ihnen so gewählt wie der
afg jetzt mit der vp traemann schließt
sich gegenseitig aus und kommt nur
karlshausen erster fonds weiter man darf
kein stauffenberg in den reihen haben
man sollte keinen stauffenberg
und wenn dann wenn man einen
stauffenberg in seinen reihen hat dann
sollte man handeln bevor dann muss man
ihn rechtzeitig finden entfernen und und
und und und für sie persönlich wer macht
es momentan am besten wäre es ihr
lieblings rechter und sehr professionell
riester fonds national mit lücken wie
machen das fachlich gesehen noch einmal
sehr sehr sehr gut
hier ist die fpö in österreich ja schon
richtig hoffähig kann man sagen
österreich ist quasi das sachsen
österreichs beste wenn es jetzt
österreich mit ostdeutschland
vergleichen und mit sachsen dann werden
da viele österreichische zuschauer
beleidigt sind jetzt ja gut das kann man
kauf nehmen so viel zur theorie
und jetzt war ich nach graz zum letzten
wahlkampfauftritt von sebastian kunst
sebastian kurz cloud ja auch relativ
viel an inhalten von der fpö also dass
er den rechtspopulisten in der sprache
sagt hier flüchtlinge aus ausländer raus
denkt man da aber der strache aber wenn
er das sagt alles ist so ein junger
hipper kälte allerdings nicht vergessen
er bringt es eigentlich so richtig so so
jung darüber wie sie sagen
sie sagen auch schön da freut man sich
genau richtig er hat eigentlich das
burka-verbot mit durchgesetzt aber in
deutschland wünschen sich dass jetzt
auch viele in österreich geschafft ja
ich würde fast schritt weiter gehen
sollte man nicht generell ist
bekleidungs verbot für frauen einführen
jetzt kann ich es eigentlich fast nicht
mehr heraus minister
was meinen sie wäre vielleicht ein
konsequent na ja das muss marseille mit
der zeit entwickelt ich bin sofort los
im bereich für sebastian kurz und ich
grüße meine mama aus deutschland hallo
sie würden sich den populären slogan
merkel muss weg auch anschließen
nach merkel muss nicht weg merkel muss
nur ihre positionen überdenken
ich glaube frau merkel hat das sehr gut
gemeint und als frau ist man
wahrscheinlich eher nach bedarf zu
schützen und zu helfen
[Musik]
sebastian kurz spricht ganze fünf
minuten und als ich ihn danach was
tragen will baut sich leider eine
bewegliche türkise wand vom jahr der
kurzer offensichtlich nur ein team für
die heute schon die schirme und hier
seit stunden abbau machte dass herr kurz
wollen sie die balkanroute genauso gut
abschirmen will die heute show die
bewegung aber können sie nicht mal
stehen bleiben wenn sie mit der äkwl
verlieren muss sich deutschlandweit
ihnen anschließen
ich war fünf minuten redezeit ist das
nicht ein bisschen viel für graz fünf
minuten redezeit hat er heute gehabt wie
hat er das durchgehalten sensationell
oder ja ich wollte ein profi ohne
erhalten und dafür unterstützung und am
sonntag gibt also nicht jeder geschafft
nicht jeder war schon ein höchste rechts
in österreich läuft momentan besser wie
in deutschland ich will auch nach
österreich will hierhin hier arbeiten
ihr leben echter österreicher seine
arbeiten sind sie willkommen das ist ja
klar wenn ich nur auf der faulen haut
liegen und ihre soziale zu in
deutschland bleiben und damit haben wir
die österreichische politik
zusammengefasst und damit zurück ins
studio
[Applaus]